[Musique]
un bon soir mardi 9 novembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 60,18 voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
un lieu dédié au savoir faire
d'excellence le campus versailles a été
inauguré ce mardi au sein de la grande
écurie du château sur place les jeunes
pourront se former aux métiers de
l'artisanat et du patrimoine charline
avenel rectrice de l'académie de
versailles est notre invité lutter
contre lille etc trop nisme c'est le but
de la maison digital dont s'est dotée la
cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines sur place des ateliers pour
apprendre à utiliser les outils
numériques sont proposés aux femmes et
10 ans bénéficient actuellement et puis
retour sur les courses de chiens de
traîneaux à plaisir ce week-end ce
rendez vous traditionnel de l'automne
s'est tenue en forêt de sainte apolline
des attelages de huit à dix chiens
étaient en lice laurent polito louis
burton qui abandonnent déjà la transat
jacques vabre on en parle également tout
à l'heure dans ce journal est le skipper
est revenu sur le démâtage de son bateau
qui lui a contraint à abandonner la
course
[Musique]
dans un instant on parle de ce campus
versailles patrimoine et artisanat
d'excellence qui a été officiellement
inauguré ce mardi 7 à versailles on en
parle je vous le disais avec charline
avenay la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles qui sera notre invité mais
d'abord ce chiffre 17 17% de la
population française est touchée par
l'électro nisme autrement dit des
difficultés à utiliser les outils
numériques à la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines des ateliers
ont été créés à l'attention des femmes
c'est le programme ensemble avec elle et
la maison digital est dit saint
quentinois en bénéficient actuellement
la maison digital elle a été inaugurée
cette semaine le reportage de mélanie
poker
sélectionnez un texte le mettre en forme
ce matin la maison digital se tient un
atelier de traitement texte dit saint
quentinois sont allés coûte leur point
commun lemondenumerique l'aurait plutôt
inconnu je voulais apprendre plus je
sais pas grand chose mais je voulais je
voulais découvrir à quoi ça va vous
servir d'accord sur les cv sur
rechercher un travail sur
sur par exemple
si je prends le métro elles sont les
premières bénéficiaires d'un programme
lancé en juin par la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines et
l'association alpha bus et les ateliers
ce sont des ateliers pour la découverte
de l'ordinateur jeu ce qui est
découverte
c'est la boîte mail
une addition internet word et excel et
aussi tout ce qui est des marches en
ligne on est aussi maintenant à un
atelier sur la mort dit et ensemble avec
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
maison digital projets accompagnés par
la fondation orange permettre à des
femmes puis teints en situation de
précarité
de s'élever socialement
professionnellement et le sérieux aussi
la cité des métiers ça faisait un
certain temps qu'il travaillait avec des
avec des femmes en difficultés et les
bilans étaient plus que positif la
fondation orange a aussi aidé à
renouveler le parc numérique de la cité
les ateliers sont animés par des membres
de l'association orange solidarité
la cité des métiers espère accompagner
une quarantaine de femmes sur cette
année
là dans l'actualité le mouvement de
grève des infirmiers anesthésistes ce
lundi 25 ont débrayé à l'hôpital mignot
au chesnay rocancourt ils ont stoppé
l'activité opératoire pour une meilleure
reconnaissance statutaire et salariale
de leur profession une grève qui est
reconductible avec ce mouvement nommé
bloc morts toute cette semaine tv 78
s'intéresse aux impacts de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie et face
à cette problématique après plus d'un an
et demi de crise sanitaire le nombre de
bénéficiaires de diverses associations
augmente ces dernières ces dernières
sont elles inquiètent pour autant c'est
l'épisode numéro deux du dossier de la
rédaction signé mélanie poker
pour
les températures fraîches sont arrivés
et aux vestiaires de l'antenne élan
courtoise du secours populaire français
les bénévoles voient les bénéficiaires
venir garnir un petit peu leur
garde-robe ce qui est certain que de
toute façon on va certainement être
amené à avoir de plus en plus de
personnes pour
pour se vêtir pour
ne serait-ce que déjà à l'alimentaire on
se rend compte aussi que il ya quand
même beaucoup plus de personnes donc et
on peut de toute façon étant donné que
c'est ouvert à tout le monde où on
souhaiterait qu'il y ait beaucoup plus
de personnes qui ne sont pas forcément
bénéficiaires mais qui pourraient
bénéficier de prix très intéressants
parmi les inquiétudes l'augmentation des
coûts de la vie au 1er octobre 2021 le
prix du gaz a connu une hausse record de
12 6% depuis le 1er janvier 2020 le
tarif réglementé a augmenté de 44% on
est en train de refaire les dossiers on
est en train de remettre à jour les
situations des personnes et donc on se
rend compte que il ya beaucoup d'impayés
de loyers où il voit des factures les
factures arrivent en ce moment de base
et les d'expliciter donc c'est
maintenant qu'ils vont découvrir que
vont pas avoir les moyens de payer
zohra et mère de six enfants son mari
est au smic elle vient régulièrement
distribution et elle subit de plein
fouet ces divers augmentation enlèvement
aura sonné pour logement il reste
presque à rien du tout pour tout le
monde c'est la vie vraiment les france
les gasoils l'espérance des voix tu es
vraiment il ya des gens comme moi car il
arrive à pas vivre la crise de la
coville a déjà augmenté le nombre de
bénéficiaires de cette antenne les
équipes ont vu arriver dix pour cent
deux personnes supplémentaires
on va on avait aussi des familles et des
hôtels sociaux mais aussi mes os
maintenant on en a aussi beaucoup plus
qu'ils viennent aussi des immeubles
sociaux achetés type hlm
donc c'est un peu pouces il ya eu une
augmentation quand même cette année avec
les problèmes de qu'ovide mais les
situations pour l'instant son nom pas
trop bouger on pense que ça va être
maintenant qu'on va découvrir les
problèmes de paiement de factures et de
d'accompagnement les 25 bénévoles de
l'antenne et l'entourent toise du
secours populaire français soutiennent
près de 50 familles bénéficiaires de
distribution sont organisées chaque
semaine
permettre aux parents et aux enfants
d'échanger et de se divertir ensemble il
ya quelques jours un premier forum dédié
à la parentalité se tenait à mantes la
jolie au programme tables rondes
ateliers activités ludiques et débats
céline charles et patrick jacques de
dixmude
comment gérer ça parentalité sereinement
prendre confiance en soi favoriser la
discussion les thèmes du forum bien-être
en famille qui s'est déroulé à
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche était varié
chacun pouvait trouver son compte en
fait avec ses intérêts en de parents
d'enfants de différents âges de
différents centres d'intérêts avoir un
environnement familial saint seurin
voilà il n'y a pas de notion de parent
parfait n'existe pas mais l'idée c'était
de donner des outils des clés aux
familles autour d'un jeu de société ou
en prenant une photo en famille parents
et enfants pouvaient se divertir
ensemble l'occasion également de
discuter et de prendre des conseils
différents débats étaient menés dans la
journée ce matin
assistez au théâtre forum et
qui était un moment hyper intéressant
très enrichissant sur
la vie en famille les situations qu'on
peut vivre au quotidien de conflits
l'idée était d'un petit circuit une
esthéticienne juste à côté une coiffeuse
qui peut mettre en valeur déjà les
et les différents membres de la famille
et puis l'idée c'était ensuite de
d'immortaliser ce petit moment en
famille et a beaucoup de créativité
il y a
beaucoup de bas du coup de com en parler
des steam de soi rien je viens de faire
une photo ça nous permet en fait de nous
voir à quoi ressemble une initiative qui
répond à un besoin des familles de se
faire aider et guider notamment depuis
le confinement 15% des français en
télétravail ou infirmer que les
relations avec leurs enfants s'étaient
dégradées des actions donc indispensable
qui projette déjà de se renouveler dans
le futur là le sport et cette mauvaise
nouvelle nous vous en parlions hier dans
le 7-8 sport l'yvelinois louis burton a
été contraint d'abandonner la 15e
transat jacques vabre avec davy beaudart
sur bureau vallée le binôme a connu une
grave avarie après seulement dix heures
de course à la voile leur imoca a démâté
cela s'est produit dimanche soir alors
que le duo deuxième à ce moment de la
compétition et voguer entre la pointe du
cotentin et l'île de guernesey fort
heureusement aucun blessé à déplorer
louis burton et davy beaudart ont rallié
saint malo ce lundi vers 18h sains et
saufs vient maintenant le temps de
l'analyse pour comprendre ce qu'il s'est
passé ils reviennent sur l'incident
regarder
faire la nam et de préparer la gestion
de la péta l'avenir et pour moi j'étais
en cockpit au mondial
[Musique]
à voir
denis sollier antibruit
cela permet de
l'important comme une mise en place de
mise en place de buddh comme ça arrive
très régulièrement et
et moins de 20 minutes après on s'est tu
au crack grosse explosion
ça fait vraiment
c'est angoissant il ya
une explosion de carbone
m la rance où résident
à l'abri on
sur la tête
le match tombe
voilà on comprend pour la démat et
maintenant on est clair on va réparer
tout ça et on va
merci mais la transat jacques vabre
relie cette année le havre à la
martinique sont 60 skipper répartis en
binômes ont pris le départ de cette 15e
édition
[Musique]
je vous en parle en ouverture de ce
journal le campus versailles patrimoine
et artisanat d'excellence a été
officiellement inauguré ce mardi il est
situé dans les bâtiments de la grande
écurie du château pour l'heure il s'agit
d'un projet pilote d'un pilote le projet
a débuté il ya deux jours il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui il prend une dimension
physique justin brasier s'est rendu sur
place
paysagisme patrimoine bâti design et
métiers d'art tourisme ou encore
gastronomie voici les domaines qui sont
enseignés au campus versailles
patrimoine et artisanat d'excellence le
pilote du projet vient d'être
officiellement inauguré ce lundi 9
novembre à versailles le pilote c'est la
préface on va dire le préfigurateur de
ce que doit être le campus de ce que
devra être le campus à horizon 2020 4
2025 puisqu'on est on occupe
actuellement en face du château de
versailles la tête de la grande écurie
qui est en face du château ces 600 m² de
plateau qui sont mises à disposition par
le château de versailles pour travailler
sur la voie professionnelle à terme en
2025 plus de 6000 m² de plateaux seront
dédiés au campus pour l'heure ici deux
diplômes universitaires ont déjà été mis
en place de la forêt au salon et de la
terre à la table objectif couvrir une
multitude de métiers pour affirmer un
projet en traitant de la sylviculture de
un aspect arboricole du design d'objet
de l'ébénisterie de menuiserie la
charpente donc on voit un maximum de
choses dans cette chaîne de valeur qu'il
y ait au bois pour qu'on puisse pour un
étudiant se positionner sur un projet
qu'il intéressera il ya le monde de
l'agriculture avec
par exemple quand on élève les animaux
on va très souvent aussi au potager du
roi qui est pas loin du tout donc du
coup
on avait déterré des carottes le campus
vise également l'hôtel à projets une
partie qui consiste à répondre à des
demandes de professionnels du château de
versailles ou encore d'enseignants c'est
le cas de ces tables modulable inspiré
des jardins de versailles pour des
salles de réunion ça nous permet donc
pour un lieu de prestige qui à
versailles de mettre en avant si notre
travail de montrer ce dont on est
capable ce dont les élèves accompagnés
des enseignants sont capables de
réaliser et ça nous permet aussi d'avoir
une expérience avec des rois dire des
vrais clients la grande rentrée a lieu
le 13 octobre pour cette première année
le campus regroupe une cinquantaine
d'étudiants et pour en parler charlie
nadal est avec mon plateau bonsoir
bonsoir rectrice de l'académie de
versailles qui s'est associé cette
académie dans ce projet au château de
versailles à c y cergy par université
aussi avec le soutien de la région ile
de france alors ça fait deux ans et non
deux jours comme je le disais tout à
l'heure que ce projet se prépare avec
des actions hors les murs le voir
aboutir aujourd'hui quel effet ça vous
fait je suis très fier très fier parce
que on est en train d'offrir aux jeunes
aux métiers de l'artisanat d'excellence
et bien un avenir qui est incroyable
c'est en somme la voie royale pour la
voie professionnelle et si on revient
aux origines du projet qu'est ce qui l'a
rendue nécessaire peut-être une crainte
de voir justement ces savoirs faire
ancestraux disparaître qu'il n'y ait
plus de main-d'oeuvre à l'avenir en
france peut-être absolument et puis et
donc plusieurs évidences sont rendus ce
campus totalement nécessaire la première
c'était ma rencontre avec catherine
pégard la présidente du château me
disant j'ai sept mille mètres carrés
mois lui disant il faut faire un campus
me disant il faut le faire sur les
métiers parce que ces métiers ont besoin
d'une nouvelle vitalité ont besoin
d'innovation ont besoin de jeunes puis
notre dame à brûler et là encore
l'évidence s'est imposée nous avons
besoin d'un appareil de ce type
complètement hybride nouveau de
formation savoir justement ces savoirs
faire ancestraux c'est primordial
justement pour innover pour continuer
d'avancer c'est ça la tension dans
laquelle on est on est pas dans le passé
on est dans l'avenir on est en train de
construire l'avenir de ces jeunes mais
on est en train de construire l'avenir
de ces métiers c'est par exemple pour ça
que l'université de cergy qui investit
beaucoup en matière de recherche sur les
sujets du patrimoine et notre temps
nerfs parce que avec elle nous pouvons
innover nous pouvons transmettre dans
les formations le plus le plus neuf de
l'innovation et de la recherche est
également le transmettre aux entreprises
qui sont associés au projet et qui elle
est aussi en ont besoin il aura tout à
l'heure sur la pédagogie de ce projet ou
parler du partenariat qui est fort sur
ce campus versailles on ne pouvait pas
faire sens pour voir naître ce campus
versailles il ya plusieurs choses qui
sont uniques d'abord un partenariat
assez improbable il est vrai entre ces
trois acteurs et bien d'autres et c'est
ça qui fait le sel du campus et puis
deuxième chose le fait que ce soit un
tiers lieux il se passe des choses dans
ce campus qui sont uniques qu'on ne
trouverait pas dans un lycée ou dans une
entreprise il se passe des rencontres
par exemple entre les artisans et les
jeunes pour leur donner envie d'aller
vers ces métiers non vous en parliez
tout à l'heure mais pourquoi versailles
pourquoi cette ville pourquoi aussi sept
grands du cul écuries du château
pourquoi elle réunissait les conditions
pour pour créer ce campus pourquoi ça
devait se faire à versailles et pas
ailleurs j'ai envie de vous parler des
jeunes et de vous dire que un jeune qui
vient de villiers-le-bel un jeune qui
vient des mureaux lorsqu'il arrive à
versailles il a un effet whaou et donc
ça c'est très inspirant on a besoin de
beaux et on a besoin de confronter les
jeunes à cette beauté évidemment la
grande écurie c'est toute une symbolique
d'abord c'est un lieu qui est magnifique
et somptueux qui rayonne en france et à
l'international
mais c'était dans le passé un lieu de
formation l'a sans doute oublié donc
c'est l'endroit idéal pour faire vivre
ces métiers et puis aussi pour se
projeter dans l'avenir et dessiner leur
futur roi qui renoue avec son passé cinq
filières sur place a été dit dans le
sujet avec une offre de formation qui
est déjà disponible et ça va monter en
puissance et ça jusqu'en 2025 ça va
monter en puissance avec des actions
dans les murs des actions hors les murs
on a parlé dans le reportage de deux
formations de la terre à la table par
exemple ou de la forêt au salon et bien
je peux annoncer ce soir que l'année
prochaine nous mettrons en place une
troisième formation de ce type de la
pierre à l'édifice des formations en un
an pour des jeunes qui sont plutôt
désorientés qui ne savent pas vers quel
métier aller et pour lesquelles on
associe la découverte des métiers mais
également du mentorat poussé de manière
très très approfondie avec une pédagogie
unique les élèves vont répondre aussi à
des commandes participer à des chantiers
d'envergure on peut citer la rénovation
de la coupole du lycée henri iv à paris
qui sera ouverte et bien des chantiers
pédagogique c'est important oui ce lien
avec le monde professionnel de les
confronter directement avec ce monde
professionnel c'est fondamental les
entreprises elles sont dans le projet
elles nous disent que ce sont des
métiers de demain elles nous disent de
quoi elles ont besoin en termes de
compétences et en effet elles nous
permettent de nous exercer sur le plâtre
par exemple sur la coopol d'henri iv
dans à rambouillet également donc
multitude de chantiers écoles vont se
développer on est dans une pédagogie par
le faire on n'est pas en train de penser
le patrimoine on est en train de le
vivre et on est en train de le faire et
un autre aspect c'est que le campus
aussi à une volonté d'ouverture de
s'ouvrir à des visiteurs peut-être de
susciter des vocations pour les
visiteurs qui se rendront sur place
alors d'ores et déjà des surfaces sont
ouvertes au public et puis plus on ira
dans le déploiement du projet en termes
de mètres carrés plus on aura de
surfaces ouvertes au public l'idée c'est
quoi c'est au fond que une famille qui
se rend à versailles qui va visiter le
château est bien puisse par ces départs
ce campus puisse s'intéresser au métier
puisse voir la transmission des
compétences et puisse avoir envie puis
savoir s'orienter dans les parcours de
formation pour les jeunes des familles
on le rappelle on est dans un pilote ça
veut dire que la once euros dont on se
teste aussi d'ici 2025 on se teste c'est
quelque chose de très important on n'a
pas la prétention de savoir très
exactement ce que nous devons faire donc
on s'essaye sur 1000 mètres carrés mille
mètres carrés qui ont pu être financées
par des mécènes la fondation bettencourt
schueller notamment et puis on déploiera
maintenant que le tour de table semble
se faire pour pouvoir
investir les deux ailes l'aide de saint
cloud elel de paris sur 7000 m² voilà
pour ce campus de verser une toute
dernière question charline avenel
c'était la rentrée hier pour plus de
trois cent mille élèves des yvelines
comment s'est passée la rentrée
globalement dans l'académie de
versailles on sait dans un contexte où
l'épidémie de e.coli 19 remonte en
france elle s'est bien passé comme elle
s'était bien passé à la rentrée de
septembre mais on rappelle que dans une
quarantaine de départements les élèves
qui avaient enlevé le masquer leurs
portes à nouveau c'est n'est pas le cas
dans les urines puisqu'on n'a jamais
retirer le masque dans les yvelines
merci charline adèle d'avoir été avec
eux et je le rappelle avec triste de
l'académie de versailles merci
avant de refermer
avant de refermer ce journal sport ont
parlé de sport tout à l'heure avec la
transat jacques vabre du sport plutôt
insolite dans les yvelines samedi et
dimanche dernier une manche de course de
chiens de traîneaux s'est tenue dans la
forêt de sainte apolline a plaisir à un
rendez vous traditionnel depuis 36 ans
et la création d'un club francilien
dédié des attelages de huit à dix chiens
ont concouru pendant tout le week end
nicolas dandois
[Musique]
mathis sentence à 21 ans est un habitué
des courses de chiens de traîneaux avec
ses 5 husky atteler à son kart il a
parcouru le tracé de 7 km 500 à travers
la forêt sainte apolline de plaisir et
pour aller plus vite il a sa stratégie
je mets un mâle et une femelle devant
pour pour avoir un peu de d'obéissance
et de et disons de vitesse pour que ça
avec les femelles sont closes hobby
sentent très mal et je mets de mal à
l'arrière pour pour donner donner une
bonne puissance à côté des cartes tracts
et au maximum par huit chiens il ya les
trottinettes et des vélos frédéric et
marjorie ont commencé il y a deux ans
chacun son chien les duos frédéric reiko
en trottinette et marjorie pria à vélo
moi j'aime beaucoup les départs avec
avec priape parce qu'elle est vraiment
dans l'excitation et donc du coup c'est
la voir comme ça on voit qu'ils prennent
plaisir à ça en fait donc c'est ce et
puis ça permet de créer un lien avec son
chien qu'on a pu peut-être moins quand
on fait moins d'activité la course dans
la forêt à plaisir un rendez vous
incontournable organisé par le club de
poule k et du traîneau à chiens
d'ile-de-france depuis 36 ans il a
rassemblé pour l'édition 2000 21 70
pilotes et entre 300 et 400 chiens qui
viennent de toute la france c'est aussi
une compétition à chaque manche les les
attelages marque des points suivant leur
classement et donc il ya un
classement en fin d'année en fin de
saison trois courses sur terre sont au
programme d'ici à la mi-décembre
viennent ensuite plusieurs étapes sur
neige jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars
puis les courses sur terre reprenne
avant la fin de la saison prévu en avril
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant le
retour du 7-8 culture une émission en
partie consacré ce soir à la réouverture
à la réouverture de la maison zola
hamedan et à son nouveau aussi musée
consacré à l' affaire dreyfus belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]